I got an interesting number sequence
it's the collar Koski sequence and I'm
just gonna write it out and see if you
can see why it might be interesting we
go one two I'm gonna put a comma in 2 2
1 1 2 1 2 2 sometimes I like to call
this the Rhodey sequence because it's
like 1 2 2 1 1 2 testing why is this
interesting this kick carries all like
this there's gonna be a pattern there
and you might think this is really
boring secrets got ones and twos and
it's that's not even any particular
order but let's look at the runs because
the numbers either kind runs of 1 or 2
interestingly so this is a run of 1 is
just 1 1 2 1 here's a run of 2 because
there are 2 of them and the run of to
run of 1 over N of 1 a run of 2 and have
you noted something very interesting
this one starts 1 2 2 1 1 2 and here 1 2
2 1 1 2 and this will continue forever
in other words the sequence describes
itself by telling you the length of the
run it's a very very famous sequence is
one of the very first ones that was put
in the online encyclopedia of integer
sequences so people just say it's the
kind of Holocaust key sequence in fact
there are only two sequences that have
this property and it's this one and this
one which is the colic Oskar sequence
without the one so begins 2 2 1 1 2 1 2
2 do you know you call a customer's bill
I name is called William William color
Koski and I know that he came up with
this idea in the 1960s
[Music]
it's like you're sort of scratching your
own back and the other hands coming back
it's like a sort of Asha painting but
done in numbers so in the book that I
did with Edmund Harris we rather he did
I would like to claim credit but I
cannot
EBIT hand a way of representing this in
the rather Russell's a beautiful way we
have the sequence starts in the outer
circle so the inner one is describing
the length of run and obviously that
therefore becomes a continuation of the
same sequence and then within it within
it within it
so rather than one sequence and then the
other one referring to it you have these
kind of concentric rings of referring
and referring and referring and that's
kind of quite interesting in quite fun
and if you do all the twos one color and
all the whites another color say one
black or gray and then one white and
then you get rid of all the numbers cuz
I'm gonna get rid of all the numbers
then you see is this kind of quite
striking this is why that's because it's
a coloring book well you know it's a
coloring book but if I had this well I
do have this but if I was not me and I
was given this I'm not sure I would want
to color it in because I think actually
that what you get from contemplating it
without color and you see how all fits
in is rather beautiful
and you're looking at it and you're
seeing there are other patterns that you
can see so you've got this sore blob
here kind of gets bigger and bigger and
bigger because what's happening is that
as they've got the rings get smaller it
happens further away so you get this
kind of shift Kolakowski sequence not
Kowalewski who wasn't there a primal
scream did a song about that I think I
think yeah because he was he was so
famous some filming the guy called cool
house key something like that anyway but
is not him
[Music]
of the mathematical things that you
might want to investigate in this
sequence is are there more ones and twos
no one knows that is another unsolved
problem a bit like the Collatz
conjecture but you'll be a lot less
famous if you get this one
[Music]
like it looks like it approaches 50% in
the limit no we don't know greatness
awaits now you might not be able to
color things in as beautifully as TIF
here but one thing you can always make
look beautiful is a website and that's
thanks to Squarespace I use them myself
all the time for multiple websites blogs
shops and you should too it's so easy
you just sit down choose between various
templates choose your domain within 30
minutes you're gonna have a website
pretty much ready to go but you can
customize it and tweak it and give it
your own personal look they've also got
great 24/7 customer support if you get
yourself into a pickle but that's pretty
unlikely to happen to find out more go
to squarespace.com and use the code
number file that will give you 10% off
your first purchase there's that website
again squarespace.com and the code
number file now thanks to them for
supporting this video seriously check
them out I use them every day